do we have a complete closure of the
Southern 215 Beltway westbound after
Buffalo and here's why Nevada State
Police Nevada Highway Patrol reporting
someone was chasing around westbound on
the 215 Southern Beltway after Buffalo
and this is the result a fire department
on scene at least one car sideways one
car may be on its top westbound drivers
are being diverted off the 215 Southern
Beltway at Durango and again we have no
we're told that there's no fatality here
but they're gonna they say there's a ton
of debris that needs to be picked up
this is a car off on its side off to the
side of the road here's a different view
of westbound 215 Southern Beltway before
you know it this is going to be backed
up not just to Buffalo not just to Jones
not just to Durango not just to Decatur
but perhaps all the way to the I-15 this
is a huge deal breaker for drivers on
the southern 215 Beltway West sound you
cannot get through after Buffalo you're
being diverted off at Durango so here's
some advice if you're westbound on the
215 Southern Beltway get off at Decatur
Jones or rainbow because there's no idea
when this is going to be cleaned up we
will keep you posted on this as we learn
more but again the westbound 215
Southern Beltway closed after Buffalo